I get to say it out loud
iRobot Ujjain machine machine learning
diversity and opportunities so you can
see quite diverse up here tons of
opportunity and I don't know one or two
AI experts so we're gonna get things
started the way we're gonna do this is
once again we're having a panel
mentality it's about looking at the
continuum of thoughts
everybody's perspectives and just having
a good time so I'm gonna look to you
Gary okay what AI technology interests
you most moving forward in the next
three years
what a AI or technology doesn't yeah no
I get it I mean I think about AI a lot I
mean I think I think what I'm most
interested in is that there's an
enormous amount of things that humans do
that is really dumb [ __ ] yeah
right and so what excites me about AI is
I think people get hyperbolized into oh
my god people gonna lose jobs and all
this things and for me I think that
people are gonna be able to focus on far
more interesting behaviors because
things are gonna be eliminated we were
told that tractors were gonna eliminate
jobs for farmers and that this was gonna
be devastating so for me at its
beginning just because I grew up as a
merchant the amount of things that are
happening in customer service that are
being used by an enormous amount of
people that the same question is being
asked over and over the elimination of
simple questions that information is at
the fingertip especially when layered on
top of a voiced device like an Alexa or
Google home has has me extremely excited
so I'm gonna go touch upon so Alexa
Google home in personal AI is what I'm
really excited about I actually
a couple years ago in like an IndieGoGo
type of personal robot I got to meet him
this year buddy
at CES it's really exciting so cool and
I I've spoken to Sofia the robot I
really look at that as definitely the
future being able to interact with AI
and having them in our lives in a daily
basis more than just Google home and
Alexa and Siri but I like for them to
become you know my personal assistant do
all the things that I don't want to do
and make my life a lot easier so I look
really forward to that happening so now
who wins and who loses with this
technology that's a good question
I think simply put those who are
prepared and are ready for what's coming
and at least understand or aware what's
coming will probably win and those that
don't
before she won't I read a report seeing
that just like self-driving cars or
vehicles the net jobs lost worldwide
will be about 60 million right and it's
not just the taxi drivers the truck
drivers losing their jobs
it's the ecosystem around them right you
hope to make us many cars you don't need
any supply areas just the truck stops
the diner's the motels the support those
guys will go away the question becomes
is what do we do with those people some
people we can probably retrain upskill
for those jobs of tomorrow which is
probably six to eight years out and some
people we can't can't tell someone
that's like in their mid 40s
married with some kids that hey guess
what you go back to school for six years
so we need to try and figure out what is
the right thing to try and do for these
people in common how does this impact
our kids and future generations what
information is very important but
something that Gary said that I thought
was it was something about how I felt
about AI when I learned that hey I was
helping a lot of farmers when it comes
to their crops to you know to really
predict because we've been having issues
with food and they were saying like you
know by the Year 2060 food was just
gonna be all messed up but our farmers
um
getting a lot of information from AI
which you know has a chance to to feed
not only our kids but feed us in a
healthy way and I think it's important
that we just continue to educate and
give as much information about it so
that our kids because we got kids out
there that are brilliant and now it's
just about exposing them to that so I
think that's how as a I was helping I
mean and we've seen it help kids who
like I said we have issues with sight
kids who've had disabilities um its
health care with education excuse me
incredible yeah it's incredible and um
and it also they've been using it to
diet to dissect when they think kids
might be looking to drop out of school
and and hopefully come up with ideas
that will keep them in school so I think
that's another way it can benefit our
youth but um I feel you know we have the
ability for it to benefit not only our
youth but us as adults too I'd love to
just build on and I just I just think
this is such a fascinating conversation
on the winners and losers we're now
three years into this conversation where
people realize certain people are gonna
lose jobs it's gonna be another five to
seven to nine to twelve years when this
starts hitting scale I struggle not that
I'm right or wrong
I struggle that if you're a truck driver
and you know autonomous trucks are
coming and you have a 12 year head start
to address your vulnerability it's hard
for me to muster up super big [ __ ]
tears for that guy or gal losing their
job when they have a 12 [ __ ] year
Head Start that this thing's going away
and I think that a lot of us are having
these conversations rightfully so
because we have a lot of compassion that
these things are gonna happen but at
some level there's a very interesting
line about accountability when this is
facing you I mean I don't feel bad for
toys-r-us going out of business nobody
cried for the bookstore's when they saw
Amazon was coming to [ __ ] get them
and so I think that there's a very
important conversation that this is
gonna take a while but when we get to
that moment where does accountability
in this knowledge but that's why what
Gary is saying is it's true but at this
and along with that that's why people
need to be exposed and get the
information so the accountability can be
like yo you knew about this you knew
about this so you could have done
something but everybody needs a fair
shake it's America we want everybody to
get a fair shake we know that's not
what's been happening but everybody
deserves until you're in to your point
that's what [ __ ] gets me so excited
about this my big thing is you could
live an Instagram explorer for nine
hours or you can get your [ __ ] google
game up you know I mean that's what's so
powerful about this you know whether
it's immigrants or minorities or female
like what what you think about the scale
of Technology its ability to potentially
level a playing field is so remarkably
powerful if I could just comment on that
I think those are both really great
points and I think that's the question
we're struggling with as a global
society because we're reaching an
inflection point now of we can do great
things right are we gonna rice the
challenge learn a deal more complex work
higher value work be more creative where
we're gonna go the route of infotainment
and watch YouTube videos watch Game of
Thrones and other things and right now I
don't know which way will break as
society but I'm looking at the future
work and I think the future is like our
data is what will allow us to earn
income so we're and also universal basic
income I think about those things all
the time
ai is taking over all the jobs and we
have to think of other ways to earn
income and of course infotainment is
definitely one of them but just
basically our own deal right now I use
Sweatt coin I are in $600 a month just
by walking that's it
so guys seem a little bit bashful I just
think this is interesting I think
history can help us so much you know
Game of Thrones or listening to music or
watching a video of somebody escapism
has always been such a foundational part
of us
that the circus was the leading [ __ ]
place that people spent money on during
the Great Depression blows my [ __ ]
head off like people people don't have
and the circus is dominating why because
life was super hard and getting those
two or three hours I'm sure you know
when I listen to an album is like that's
escapism that's look for me to balance
it's a very interesting human trait that
we you know are thinking about and I
just think it's a remarkable time so
just to kind of bring this together to
balance the two of you and bring this
panel together when we're going to the
humanism view of this once we've equaled
the playing field if you're not moving
forward you're moving backwards right
we're all accountable for it whatever we
do next
true all right guys I want to go off
script so I want to kind of play on what
you guys were talking about and bring
you guys in and you all seem very
comfortable so bear with okay there's
this common misconception we talk about
artificial intelligence right it's an
amalgamation of technologies computer
vision NLP voice recognition data
processing in the cloud storage in the
cloud many many other things robotics
and this idea that it's going to be part
of this fourth Industrial Revolution
where we're gonna disintermediate
everything and put everybody out of work
is often misconceived
right because some people would say that
the jobs are gonna go to the first or
the highest paid repetitive and highly
objective jobs arguably radiologists are
more at risk than a truck driver so I
want to kind of go through that and ask
your opinion on what jobs you actually
think change and what sort of
opportunities that open up for us comedy
okay if I start with you well yeah you
can start with me I know one thing that
a job you won't lose if you're a good
artist I mean I also think you know as
Gary was alluding to certain forms of
entertainment and things that we enjoy
you're just not gonna lose that job like
I mean I still want to see LeBron James
you know like simple as that like can't
replace that you can't replace that
you can't replace Frank Ocean you know
you can't replace common you know the
thing they did with Tupac and all those
Holograms holograms but there's nothing
like having the real thing yeah all
right man thank you Gary let's bring it
your way don't walk it down guys look I
think I mean you nailed it anything
that's repetitive and done you know on
the back of you know technology or you
know is going to be fundamentally
vulnerable yeah so you know it's funny
same thing with the internet I remember
when the internet like started becoming
real and people actually had a well I
remember thinking with with Amazon hey
bookstores it's your turn right and then
uber came along and it was taxicabs it's
your turn you know to me everybody's
gonna have a turn outside of that that
is black and white I think what Commons
referring to in which is so powerful
about art is that it's gray right I
think anything that is black and white
is remarkably vulnerable there's so many
things that are done there by people
that are typing away at a computer that
are a human typing away at a computer to
create an action for another human is
100% vulnerable mm-hmm whoo what about
you
I look at this as an opportunity for all
of us to become polymaths Renaissance
men and women to be the day of being
specialized in a skill that's not
happening anymore you know right like
common you're an artist but now you're
also doing tech stuff I used to do so
many different things before I did this
I was a behavioral therapist I had a VR
company our company a blockchain company
I'm a VC so many things I look at this
is a real opportunity for us to learn so
many different things and let let the AI
take all the repetitive jobs they should
I don't think there should be any more
slave labor this is an opportunity like
I I was just in China for the last month
and there's no recycling at where I was
because they have humans to ever
separate all the recycling well for that
country for those people
really thrive they can start thinking
about more things than just surviving
when they I can take over it and because
of that little smartphone they can all
look at becoming infotainment
on their entertainment and their data
that's really exciting I agree that's
great so Neil I want to close with you
on this one you you are you're very
modest but you are a master inventor you
are a master prognosticator what what do
you see happening here I I want to start
by just trying to summon up that
machines are about productivity and
people are about creativity right there
are things that machines do better than
people but there are things that people
do much better than machines and we have
to keep that in mind and I think what's
going on today's people are surprised by
some of the things that machines are
good at people say well ok driving a
taxi or a bus that's one thing but how
can I do something a lawyer can do but
if you think about some of the tasks
that you know lawyers do coming out of
law school they're very productive type
of tasks and the goal is not to you
we're gonna replace all those guys with
that we're gonna free their time up to
do more complex work more creative type
of work and maybe that's case strategy
maybe that's more engagement and
understanding the client and what's
going on I think what we really have to
deal with again as a society is
understanding how our work how our lives
are gonna be transformed by this what
could we do that's more that's more
creative and I don't think this is a
unique challenge for us you know
technology has always been there and
reshaping our lives I think it's that
the changes are coming faster and faster
and I think that's what people are
struggling with is the stuff we're
talking about is not twenty years away
in some cases it's not even five years
away it's already here what do we do so
this shift that we're talking about
opens up a subject and this is a unique
panel because we can go from deep tech
to diversity and culture and so I want
to hand this one off to Denise because
obviously this cues you up beautifully
for the next question on what this means
absolutely so at the end of the day guys
the tech industry has taken a lot of
fire for not being diverse especially at
the top echelon so why is diversity
important what does it mean to the
future and what opportunities does it
bring
can I start with this this is something
I'm super passionate about I started the
women in black chain foundation to
address this specifically I was tired of
being the only woman at the table in
every tech company and every meeting and
yes women join join a telegram channel
but it's it's it's really important for
us to be diverse because if you if you
think about it on a technological layer
if you look at box chain all around the
world in every corner of the universe
well if it's in every corner of the
universe it's going to take everyone in
every corner of the universe to be put
in this and that has to be more than
just you know a white guy it has to be
every single one of us and if we're
talking about the new era of wealth
creation it has to include because in
the dot-com era it was mainly men it's
like 90 percent men were able to gain
from this well here's an opportunity I
myself have been able to gain from this
and I want everyone else to come with me
and join this revolution so I'm so
passionate so yes diversity is very
important everyone needs to come on
board and educate yourself do whatever
it takes you know look at every YouTube
channel follow Gary and everything you
know there's so much out there just do
what it takes and get everyone to join
you well said yeah and I you know I mean
this is the world man everybody has
something to offer like it's just we
just all have something to give to this
world and and Jeff brought up something
when I was talking back there like that
I a community that I didn't acknowledge
was the Native American the First Nation
brothers and sisters who I saw at one
point actually getting in tune with some
AI technology to through something I was
doing with Microsoft and it was like man
so many gifts have been given to the
world from
different cultures and and from women
and men and from people from from Africa
to to India to you know to the United
States and they come from so many
different backgrounds so it's it's
important that we that we get to use use
our technology and have diversity but
it's also one of the things that's
important that that we educate first so
the people that are the people that
we're asking to step up and see these
jobs are prepared and have what what
Gary said the accountability to do it
but then we also have to recognize some
of these companies the people the
higher-ups have to be diverse to like we
have to have diverse people in the
boardrooms making decisions or it's just
like or it's just basically like what
we've been seeing in our country for so
many years yeah we're gonna we're gonna
make it diverse we're gonna make you
know bring more people of color in but
are they making any decisions are they
getting any opportunities to be a part
of some of the significant change to
skip coming from up top and that's where
I think diversity is gonna have to start
from the education and of in the top
there's so many levels to get to
diversity to be honest yeah I was born
in Belarus and the former Soviet Union
to me it's it's a it's a very important
subject because take out the first of
all it's human if you are not a human
that believes in it you're you're
unbelievably vulnerable and and
unbelievably in a defensive negative
place but take that away let's just make
it raw about business and like make it
about what people tend to make it about
perspective and context our strengths
not weaknesses to only it's almost like
if we were talking what if we talked
about food you know shitty it would be
to just eat Italian food
you know Italian foods [ __ ] rad but
it would make no sense and so for me I'm
fascinated by companies that all look
the same all the decision makers look
the same to me very honestly especially
an environment we now live in today and
I don't mean the political environment I
mean just where the evolution of
Technology and opportunities are it's a
vulnerability it's laughable to not take
context from all walks of life from
different angles I'll tell you one that
I'm unbelievably fascinated about that
is not talked enough about in technology
tech you know we talk up thank God we're
talking so much about brown and black
and minorities and females but we don't
talk about ageism at all you know
I'm unbelievably a big fan of people in
their 60s 70s 80s and 90s because I
think they have deep context for [ __ ]
life
but people that are 70 and above are
completely getting [ __ ] on in our in our
ecosystem and so I've been thinking a
lot about starting an incubator that is
actually incubated out of a retirement
home so I've always thought you know I
came from a whole lot of little and so I
always thought I had an advantage
because I think adversity is an
advantage
so I think in general why is it
important because you'll do better [ __ ]
if you have a divorce diverse team if
we're not representing the entire
stakeholder environment at the very top
you're vulnerable I'm also concerned
about like who's programming this AI if
it's not from a diverse crowd of people
who were to program we're not gonna get
the protocols that are needed to
represent what we want this is one
demand this is way more important than
people think I'll give you the comp in
real life everything for a long time was
just made for righties what about
[ __ ] lefties Yeah right yeah so
people may hear that and it may not
understand but if you're a who's a lefty
out there right so I think
neela we wouldn't leave you out of this
conversation a hundred percent agree
with everybody and if we write you up a
really critical point because you've
already seen with some AI solutions
there's inadvertent bias and the
training right you look at google vision
I know those guys didn't mean to do it
but it was really good at recognizing
white men and that's so much anybody
else because it was built and trained by
white man and I think as we're moving
forward doesn't become more integrated
in our lives and it's gonna start doing
more to assist us with decision making
making sure that training is as bi as
free as possible has the
multi-perspective is going to be
critical I can tell you that in my work
with the United Nations in the span of
about six months a lot of the world
leaders went from is this a Skynet type
of thing - we need robot judges robot
judges are to reduce bias the court
system helped more people that kind of
stuff but it all boils down to that
training and without the right diversity
we're gonna keep making those same
mistakes shift gears just a little bit
and take a time trip back with me
everybody on this stage is a product of
the third digital revolution we grew up
with micro electronics revolution
digital information technology
information systems it's foundational
changed everybody here you roll the
clock back 4050 years we had just landed
on the moon the idea of private rockets
was ridiculous unless you were building
them in your backyard there were no
microwave ovens there were no
smartphones there were no cell phones
the Internet as we know it wasn't
invented in fact its predecessor ARPANET
only started in 1983 stem cells nobody
even knew what the genome was at that
time so I want you to put your thinking
hats on and tell me as we move to the
precipice of this fourth digital
revolution right we are saying
unprecedented technology we have quantum
computing coming which changes
everything possible nuclear fusion as a
power source
we now have robotics artificial
intelligence machine learning and more
computational power on a phone that Gary
pulled out of his pocket then used to
run universities right so play it
forward to 2050 Neil I'm gonna start at
this side with you because you you this
is your job this is where you live what
you do for right plus we got this aim
here could I like
this was planned by the way tell me and
tell this crowd what you think we can
expect I will tell you we're moving so
fast it's really difficult if I were to
run the clock back just ten years who
were to predict it something like uber
right I think if we're going to 2050
what's gonna happen I can I'm gonna
throw it out there and say one word
cyborgs
we're already seeing a big move towards
human computer integration they've
already done like experimental surgery
and they could put digital cameras that
are blind person's eyes and transmit the
image so they can see I think 2050 will
be cyborgs
who I'm already into that now I look at
us being able to have not only cyborgs
here on earth but doing stuff in on
other planets I already started my own
embryo portfolio so that I could have my
own progeny in Mars when we start doing
that I think that's the future my own
one concern is that when the cyborgs
come that there will be less human
interaction interaction like I won't
need a man anymore cuz I have my own sex
robot but I think there will be a lot of
training needed for us to interact with
humans so that job will be available URI
your thoughts I hope I think sex robots
are gonna be [ __ ] amazing so I'm not
super like passionate about the
nostradamus business you know I there's
a lot of things that were gonna be
closed on there's gonna be a billion
things that we could never even think
about you know for me what stands out is
what I'm fascinated by technology is I
think
it's throwing us back if you ask me the
best indicator of where we'll be in 2050
I think things that we were doing in the
17 and 1800's play out let me give you
an example let me give you the one that
really stands out for me what what
social media has done is it's allowed us
to know much more about each other than
we ever could before at scale which was
far more similar to what was happening
in the old days when your little
community was your whole world and you
did know everything about every massive
extension of the vieta so hundreds of
the more interesting things to think
about in 2050 and maybe 2100 is I think
things that we've put on pedestal
religions marriages are gonna become
dramatically more vulnerable well III
think that the shadows of our society
are being exposed by technology there's
nowhere to hide and I think most of the
institutions that we hold near and dear
are actually built up by the shadows of
our society and so I think this gets a
hell of a lot more emotional than people
think I actually hope that we become a
hell of a lot less hypocritical once we
realize that we all have [ __ ]
skeletons and we all have massive flaws
which will then allow us to have a
hundred years of pain which will then
lead to a hundred years of nirvana
I like coming gonna bring this one home
for me you mean work absolutely
everywhere I mean look you're asking the
person in Friday least has the ideas of
where we'll be in 2050 I am a person
that likes to stay in the present but if
I do I have a album called B and I was
about being in the present just being
present right but if I do have to think
about the future in an hour
what I would like to see ai and
technology bring us maybe we have a cure
for cancer through
and and as we talked about earlier maybe
it'll be healthier foods being put in
neighborhoods that don't get healthy
foods because the technology and maybe
we can even use technology to advance
rehabilitation as I talked about in
prisons I'm just talking about dreams I
got right maybe technology or help bring
us together more as people and what in
love would be the center of it in
technology or just be a tool of it so
those are the things that I dream of in
my dream world cuz I'm a dreamer but
right now I'm staying the president I'm
grateful to be here with you brilliant
people beautiful man thank you thank you
I think we can all agree to that but all
good things have to come to an end and a
huge round of applause for our guests